is skinamarink the scariest film ever
made or a nonsensical nightmare why not
both every year a new horror movie comes
along that's billed as an Alzheimer 2022
saw the release of terrifier 2 an
independent slasher that became an
unlikely mainstream success story after
it made fans physically sick at
screenings this year though Skidamarink
is the hot new horror flick on the Block
that people are already hailing as a
future classic Skidamarink has in fact
been described as the scariest film ever
made by some shaken reviewers that's
High Praise And it remains to be seen if
it will stand the test of time but
there's no denying that the hype
surrounding Carl Edward Ball's debut
feature is exciting and morbidly
alluring skinamarink is the type of
horror movie that Taps into the Primal
essence of fear according to the
twitterverse one spooked fan posted
there is a single line in Kyle Edward
Ball's magnificent skinamarink that has
haunted me for months this total
freakout's awareness us and praise is
well deserved feeling freaked out was a
common response with another fan posting
Skinnamarink freaked me the hell out as
few horror films have another fan
meanwhile warned that the movie will
terrify even the most hardened and
experienced horror fans writing I
watched Skinnamarink by Carl Edward ball
last night with the lights out at
midnight and I'm pretty sure it's the
first movie to really scare me in 20
years I was terrified elsewhere another
moviegoer thanked literal Jesus that
they didn't watch it alone writing I
actually don't think I could have done
it that's a lot coming from me
furthermore some horror fans have
praised Skidamarink for being original
and breathing life into a genre that's
associated with familiarity and death
like this man who wrote I hope
skinamarink gets the appreciation it
deserves I really really loved it it's
by far the most unique Haunted House
movie I've ever seen there are many
horror fans out there who balk at the
thought of yet another found footage
movie for some the format has been
overused by too many low budget
filmmakers who don't know how to make
the most of it when they're at their
best though found footage movies thrust
the viewer Into the Heart of Darkness
and provide them with an immersive
experience According to some fans
skinamarink is a prime example of found
footage horror at its best right up
there with movies like The Blair Witch
Project Paranormal Activity and Cannibal
Holocaust at the same time Kyle Edward
Ball's feature is a beast unto itself
that's comparable to nothing else one
fan posted this movie is the exact
embodiment of what all found footage
horror attempts to be absolutely
excellent skinamarink is a horror movie
that favors mood atmosphere and
nightmarish qualities over a traditional
narrative and explaining the plot would
spoil its ghoulish shocks and surprises
all you need to know is that it revolves
around two children who wake up in the
middle of the night to discover that
their father is missing and all of the
windows and doors to their home have
disappeared
that's it I am not going back in there
come on you chicken it's just a movie as
documented by Rotten Tomatoes many
reviewers have commented on the film's
experimental qualities in fact most
viewers will probably come out of
skinamarink scratching their heads and
wondering what they just watched at the
same time the movie Taps interferes that
most people have been able to relate to
at some point in their lives namely
being a child and feeling anxious about
monsters and the thought of our
Guardians disappearing Kyle Edward ball
told inverse that the confusion is to
quote another recent horror hit all part
of the menu ball told the outlet it's
personal sentimental and feels personal
to other people it's also childlike and
makes no sense
foreign
[Music]